all right we have a such a good show
tonight and of course it's summer I
mentioned it really is it's very hot
it's summer it's the dead of summer dead
of summer means heat it also means a lot
of big rock acts are on tour right now
that's a way a lot of people keep cool
they go out at night and they see these
big rock and roll arena shows well our
old friend triumph the insult comic dog
who's been a good friend of ours
he said he told us he'd like to check
out the hottest act that is playing in
our in our area and no I'm not talking
about Madonna I'm talking of course
about Bon Jovi yeah oh my god all right
well anyway triumph said he wanted to go
and check out Bon Jovi and the Bon Jovi
show so he went he brought a camera crew
here's what happened the electricity
here in the New Jersey air is almost as
powerful as the other smells juvie
returns to its home state much like Pope
returning up into the bath hole this New
Jersey stadium will be filled by 80,000
people with 200 steady jobs as Bon Jovi
renders it's rare brand of magic yes you
[ __ ] to get an idea of the Bon Jovi
sound try to imagine Bruce Springsteen
coming out of my ass how much did you
pay to see the show tonight $40 $40
wouldn't it have been better to wait
till next year when they're playing at
Six Flags
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
jump it where the press gets to ask
questions of bon jovi quite a turnout as
you can see everyone is here people have
come from as far as exit where all the
original band members or is it like
lassie where they just replace you with
identical Jack now look at this look at
this this is there are such big fans
they put my face my likeness on there
[Applause]
here's your first album and there's John
on the cover look at you that's right
before Eddie Murphy drove by and picked
you up now let's talk about some of
these songs look at this here's the
lyric sheet boy on a steel horse I
arrived
okay so Ritchie works out the rhymes
while you oil his bath
which is sambuca your yes you're married
to Heather Locklear yes he stops Heather
Locklear I'm a fan
can I get personal for a second sure she
doggy dog this is a man he's been
everywhere man this guy went out with
Cher back when she was only in her
sixties so you're acting now you know
you're in a vampire movie yes yes that's
good
finally a role that requires you to sign
[Applause]
here is the real heterosexuals the
rowdiness right so the Punjabi world
tour yes yes and then what then it's
back to being carnies yes you're going
to amplify this crap something
interesting
oh look at is the setlist for tonight
1989 oh crap where's the real action
here right it's on the bus on the bus
oh the bars I like the sound of them
alright let's see what we got here are
you guys doing oh look at this alright
what you guys got there what you guys
got there yeah yeah it's cool it's cool
man it's totally cool don't worry about
me I wasn't born yesterday
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys man what if your day
just you
was my being
[Music]
[Music]
three hours on his hair Little Rock
Amaya I'm here with mr. McGrath the lead
singer of Sugar Ray which was the
opening act for Bon Jovi technically
that means that you're considered not as
good as Pancho key what we're loved look
at his banjo
what part of ninety million records
shows the six line record you know I'm
talking about now their career is colder
than an Iditarod okay in the 80s did
Richie feather his views
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know Samara don't feel like
anything
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's an artist 20 insult comic dog with
innovate we come back Helen Hunt's is
gonna join us will stay my second